Gavin Newsom uh is thinking of running
for the president of the United States
He is the most uh one of the most hated
politicians from the most hated state in
the Union Gavin Newsom has now released
an ad that says that he is going to try
or planning potentially to be a
contender and you know
Biden's senile and a corpse Kamal is
incredibly unpopular Hillary uh too old
unpopular there aren't many options for
the Democrats right the Republicans have
DeSantis seemingly maybe Trump probably
DeSantis Gavin Newsom definitely seems
to be
um
now the original version of this ad by
the way
um and which is good which is why they
had drag queens twerking and then
eight-year-olds just making it rain on
them
that's it was the original version of
the ad
um and it was they had it in uh it was
set right on um the universe a lot we're
proud of that in California Universal
Studios and and it's just eight
nine-year-olds just making it rain on on
the drag queens of the drag queens are
just twerking with their g-strings off
and then Gavin Newsom
stands in the middle and he goes you're
going to pay for gas [ __ ]
and then all the drag queens go yes
daddy and then they start whipping him
with a leather thing and then it says
Gavin Newsome hey America how about this
and this is a question mark
um
that's the was the original ad they ran
that in focus groups now people got
really testy
about that Gavin Newsom didn't
understand why he said it was a drag
queen birthday party what's the big deal
it was a normal California drag birthday
party and with some leather daddy BDSM
uh climate uh uh content appropriate
climate content where you know
because gaviness says listen the reality
of the situation is and you know and
it's like it's like we're saving the
planet
um
the I mean and I'm not even kidding like
the original slogan that they were
testing again and I'm not folks people
get so mad at me when I report the news
I don't I barely Give opinions on these
things
Gavin newsom's campaign ad
the slogan that they were testing was we
are going to save the planet
for child drag queens
and and and it was just child drag
children in Drag
and and Gavin Newsom because this is the
future
now
I that slogan did horribly when it was
tested so now they've now they have this
where he's I don't he's standing in a
yard that's meant to look like by the
way Landscaping on this yard now that I
know you look at it around 20 to 30k
just on the landscaping around but he's
trying to like appeal to people and seem
like he's Gavin Newsom as the great red
company have said many times is in
defeat wine merchant what that means is
that he has a state in Northern
California where he wanders around in a
robe and drinks like barolo drinking red
wine he he's never been to Los Angeles
he doesn't know what it is because in
his words Latinos are confusing he goes
not good or bad but I don't know who's
who this is what he said to his wife now
so which by the way he was married to
that Kimberly Guilfoyle Newsome who's
now married to uh Donald Trump Jr
because one thing she likes is authentic
connections she she's in it for love
Kimberly Guilfoyle Newsome first wife
and so was he he wanted that big-titted
monster too so see he he's not how do
you let him off right he knew what was
going on so Gavin Newsom now is
um
what they're doing now in California is
if you have a birthday party for your
children there have to be drag queens
there that is a requirement in
California
at least one at least one drag queen
at the party
um
that's it's a requirement let's play now
of course we're kidding around here I
don't think that's a law yet
um keep the kids out of the bars I've
said it before
gay people should be a little more
should be more vocal on this it
shouldn't only be like right-wing
Christian types that say this it is
incredibly inappropriate for any
children to be throwing money at a drag
queen or a stripper or children
stripping themselves children should be
left alone to figure out who they are uh
and that's the position of of sane
people okay except in the state of
California because kids in the state of
California are Advanced so if they want
to twerk on their birthday they should
be allowed to there's a lot of kids that
go to their parents and say listen I
want this to be a 70s style bath house
for my birthday can I do Bath House
theme
and the parents have to and the parents
are straight of course but they're they
are you know they have virtue so they go
well and they talk about it they go hey
Mike yeah
we're gonna do pizza party but you know
some of the kids are they have gluten
and sensitivities so that's going to be
tough so our son Mike wants to do 70s
Bath House theme
which you know would mean that all the
kids and the parents you know rent out
like a bath house and everybody goes in
and like simulate the conditions of an
orgy
but not have them but like show people
that it's like okay and fun
so they want to do bad house and like
glory holes but the cupcakes go through
this is
um so here is this is what I mean it's
like let the kids figure out who they
are there's zero reason for a kid to
really be in a bar I used to watch my
father play music in a bar my family
would bring me in
and I'd stand there and watch that near
do well uh strum guitar and he was very
good at it you know and he you know he
used to play with this guy Gary and Gary
was on the uh you know the keyboards the
synth and my father was on the guitar
and I was like a young kid and I'd go
watch him play music instead of um raise
me and it was uh bad for for me it's
actually bad for me I shouldn't have
been there so I just think kids should
be left alone and I I I I it's handing
it's handing Christian Looney Tunes an
issue it's going here you go
here's your issue
if you want freedom if you want you know
women to be able to have abortions
during a reasonable window
if you want uh people to be able to
marry who they want if you want Society
to kind of progress in a way that does
it completely abandon morality and
judgment you cannot have children and I
don't know who is doing this
who is doing this
now certain
certain things are okay
certain kids my friend is doing it uh
her daughter
they're doing dikes on bikes for the
kids where all the kids are gonna get on
motorcycles with lesbians and ride out
into the desert
that's fine
because lesbians don't have sex it's not
sexual at all
lesbians are just creatures
from an ancient past chupacabras
so there's nothing sexual about that so
there's nothing wrong with the kids
getting on the motor because the kids
are on the motorcycles and they go out
to the desert with the dikes fine
um
here's another thing which I don't know
if I love
friend of mine
his four-year-old they're doing a rent
themed birthday
the show rent
well I'm all for Broadway
but the kids are gonna each pick a
character from rent someone's gonna be
the heroin addict who does anal Mimi
someone's gonna be uh the transgender
person Angel who has AIDS
someone's gonna be Mark who has AIDS
someone's gonna be Adam who has AIDS
someone's gonna be the black guy I
forget his name he sings Santa Fe which
I love let's open up a restaurant in
Santa Fe
what a great song
uh Collins I forget his name don't look
it up the point is he's doing there's a
four-year-old right and because the
four-year-old said to the parents who
came to the parents and said can we do a
rent themed party
where everyone pretends to have AIDS
um
so I don't know how I feel about that
but
I don't think it's the worst idea
if all the kids can know that they don't
have AIDS
foreign
Queens you know for the most part it's
like adult entertainment you know we
should have adult entertainment in
America and drag queens you know I think
the fun of drag is that they are acerbic
and witty and they say things that are
inappropriate and usually it's late at
night and they're funny and sexual in
certain instances not always drag
inherently isn't sexual it's kind of
buffoonish and clownish but there are
moments of it that are certainly
inappropriate for kids
um I also think drag queens you know
they're inappropriate they're fun they
do low brow racial ethnic humor I've
always seen that I think it's great
um I don't think that PC drag queens I
mean what a hellish nightmare drag
queens reading books at library who
wants to read books to kids at life can
you imagine if we had to do that like
every Sunday we had to go
read books to these illiterate junkies
in this country
let's watch this this Gavin newsom's
gonna be the president now yeah and he's
airing this in uh Florida Gavin newsom's
airing it in the swing set him and
desanta should go in they're going Hog
Wild
by the way Florida parties for the kids
they're doing and I and here again you
might not like it
um
my friend lives in Florida I'm not even
kidding
he said we're doing a party and it's
called it is the theme of the party is
Parkland but the kids win this time
so the theme of the party is Parkland
but the kids win so the kids get
guns that are not loaded we hope and the
job of the kids they run around and a
kid comes in and they pointed them they
go look at that anti-social communist
and then they get them
before he gets them
Gavin news from the president
it's Independence Day oh let's talk
about what's going on in America Freedom
it's under attack in your state and
Republican leaders they're banning books
making it harder to vote restricting
speech in classrooms even criminalizing
women and doctors I urge all of you
living in Florida by the way I joined
the fight I mean I'm so PR I'm
pro-choice guy but I just love the idea
of criminalizing women
and I'm wondering can I can I
criminalize women while still being
pro-choice
like is there a way
to criminalize women while letting them
have abortions
because that fascinates me that hits me
right in the political sweet spot if
there ever was one
if there ever was a way to really speak
to Tim Dillon it's remaining kind of
libertarian minded and allowing people
to have freedoms but also finding a way
to criminalize women just that coupling
of words makes me uh get out the
checkbook
and donate I don't know how that's being
done
but just just women starting as
criminals and then having to prove
they're not I like that idea
much like how people are born with
original sin
uh women being criminals first and then
what's he said let's finish this up here
join the fight with Gavin Newsom or join
us in California where we still believe
in Freedom doesn't look like that by the
way back go back to that freedom go back
to that
nothing
nothing looks like what they they no
State let me tell you right now I just
returned from the greatest state that
God ever gave man New York
uh where we have the Hamptons which is a
beautiful
Community is stunningly
it's breathtaking
um
so many different types of white people
on pills
you know what I mean like so many
different types of like those long white
stare like kind of like
you have this yeah
and you have the Surfer which is a
little more like
but
a couple of women there on the pills get
off the bagels ladies because you know
in the Hamptons the women have to
and I have a friend there who's managing
my home there issues of fatty boombathi
and the women uh aren't kind to her
because of that uh a fat uh rotund pink
cherubic man in the Hamptons is treated
as he should be like a god who fell from
the clouds because he might have a lot
of money
but the young mommies do not like big
ladies
they don't like it
um and I was just there and it's pretty
and it holds up New York City holds up
when you go you go I've seen it on a
bunch of films this is kind of what it
looks like when you go to California
there's uh there's some type of like
wait what
wait huh
there's very few places that hold up
some up north Big Sur that area fine
Beverly Hills of course is Beverly Hills
but the vast majority of California is
it just does not present as you would
think it does it has done a great
Hoodwink California is you know it's a
it's a dating profile you know that's a
little misleading
for sure
not a straight up catfish but like where
you go oh God like when you see the
person at the table you know this
feeling you're walking to the coffee
table and you see the person from about
let's say 10 meters away and your first
response is I hope to God this isn't
what it is and you know down deep that
it is and you have to sit down with them
anyway
um while they like you know eat their
coffee they like chew it
listen to me
um
I also going to read comp earlier Peter
Schiff is in trouble now they're trying
to get him for his bank I don't know why
he's running a bank
Peterson's running a Puerto Rican Bank
but you know
people do what they do and we support
Chef never support the feds never
support the feds Peter Schiff owns a
bank with Jake Paul who cares so what
so what it's nice to have a bank why
don't you get a bank
they're mad at him because they said his
Capital requirements he doesn't have any
money in the bank
stop this I don't know I don't know
enough about it to even go into it I
don't know enough about it we want to
try to get him on the show let's get him
on the show he's he's he's honest he's
in trouble they're trying to get him
um
so let's let's watch this by the way
Because by the way just get can you
freeze on the picture of Santa Monica uh
was that right before this yeah yes so
freeze it here okay okay I don't know
what year
this was taken
look how far away you are by the way
this is kind of funny and interesting
look how far away you are this is
essentially an aerial shot of California
this is where California still can look
somewhat desirable from the air this is
so far away from anything
um
now I just want you to Google in another
tab Santa Monica homeless because Santa
Monica is one of the scariest places
you'll ever go I was there the other day
and the people just walk around
screaming at the sun like cursing God I
mean
yeah any photo unemployed so that that's
up close
what Santa Monica looks like that's the
same area in there that's the same area
that you're looking at from the aerial
Sean
um
yeah it's the same one right there there
it is that's what it looks like up close
okay
endless tent cities now go to the area
oh yeah isn't that Purdy that looks
pretty so what again it's a trick of
Hollywood they're lying to you they are
making it seem like California is an
idyllic Paradise when in fact it is not
the only thing that is the also the rest
of the country is also a dump
so unless you can live in like Jackson
Hall Palm Beach
East Hampton like there's like 10 places
in the country that aren't a complete
dump
so that's that's a benefit to California
um
watch let's watch the rest of this ad
but we still believe in freedom freedom
of speech no you don't listen Freedom
not only do you not believe in Freedom
this state is not free they take all of
your money you don't get to uh I mean
the vaccine thing they went nuts
lockdowns they they absolutely don't
believe in free it's so
you know why why not just honest
political ads
why not just honest political ads no I
mean they like genuinely with like stop
cut this [ __ ] about like well if
we're free and then your state they
don't like free and it's like
what do you want
what do you want
like like literally it's a guy like
[ __ ] Newsome going looking at you and
going what do you care about and who do
you want to see killed
do you agree with us you like what we
like you want to kill the people we want
to kill or the other way around
because that's all it is
what do you like which natural disasters
do you like and who do you disagree with
on a level where if they were a victim
of natural disaster you'd say good
that's real political ads it's none of
this [ __ ]
about this this beautiful uh mixed race
family by the way
this is
um
freedom from hate and the freedom to
love
so you have a mixed race family here
the freedom to hate and the Freedom From
Love okay
that family which I don't know if it's
real or not okay
each of them has to work 19 hours a day
to afford their 19 000 Mortgage in this
state
so there's not a lot of freedom left
after you've worked every hour that
you're alive
and there's not a lot of freedom to
raise your children unless you can
afford you know to really have the time
to be with them that's the other issue
they don't want to talk about how
unaffordable California is
keep going hate and the freedom to love
don't let them take your freedom paid
for by Newsome for California Governor
2022.
yeah I mean listen it's not it's not
that uh it's not uh God what is this
here oh God uh I think this is that Gary
Chambers guy I don't know what he is I
can't I don't have anything for him so
let's just move on
uh scars and bars guy
great whatever that means God bless him
yeah he's a Democrat from Louisiana
running for the Senate good for him I
don't know what anything means anymore
um
he does a campaign in where he burns
Confederate flag okay cool cool hey man
my best to you uh but everywhere is a
dump right Florida's a dump outside of a
few places so I mean you know what are
you gonna do your brother's head
homeless getting bad in Dallas yeah he
said they're gonna get bad everywhere I
know that it's fun to hit California
over the head because they have crazy
policies and they've brought this on
themselves encouraged it some of it's
the climb it but homelessness is going
to get bad everywhere for the simple
fact that um drugs are becoming the only
thing that work uh to alleviate the
hellscape we've created
foreign
yeah I mean those are the only things
that work right so drugs drugs tend to
work very well
um the problem is they have a lot of
unintended consequences that knock
people
uh down a few pegs in life and
unfortunately it's hard to climb out of
that hole